Welcome to today's deep dive. I'm your host. And today we're going to explore something really fascinating for those of you out there building, you know, conversational interfaces. I'm joined by our resident AI architecture expert.
Hey, thanks for having me. I am really excited to dig into this one because, frankly, the way we build voice tech right now is just entirely broken.
It really is. I mean, think about the last time you spoke to a standard voice assistant.
Yeah.
You say the wake word, you ask your question, and then just wait.
Yeah, that palpable, awkward pause.
Exactly. It's this rigid, walkie-talkie style of turn-taking. And that silence you hear, it isn't the machine thinking. It's actually the sound of an architectural bottleneck.
Right, because the current paradigm treats human conversation essentially like a game of chess. One player has to completely finish their turn, hit a timer, and wait for the other player to move. But natural human communication doesn't look anything like that.
Not at all.
If you look at the linguistics data, the average response time across human languages is about 230 milliseconds. Wow, that fast. Yeah, 230 milliseconds. And beyond that, 10 to 20 percent of our spoken time actually involves overlapping
speech. We interject, we finish each other's sentences.
Right. Or we back channel with a yeah or an uh-huh while the other person is still talking, just like I'm doing right now.
Exactly. And standard cascaded voice systems physically cannot handle that kind of dynamic interaction. They rely on this rigid step-by-step pipeline.
Right. So first, voice activity detection, or VAD, monitors your microphone to figure out if you've actually stopped speaking.
Yep. Then automatic speech recognition steps in to transcribe your audio into text. That text gets fed into a large language model.
Which generates a text reply.
Right. And finally, a text-to-speech engine synthesizes that text back into audio. The entire process takes several seconds.
And if you happen to, like, cough or say, hmm, while the agent is talking, the pipeline either completely crashes or treats your interruption as a fatal error.
It's terrible. It starts the whole slow process over again. But we are looking at a research paper today from Kutai Labs that details a model called Moshi, which completely abandons that cascaded pipeline.
And Moshi is the first real-time, full-duplex, spoken, large-language model, right?
It is. It aims for a theoretical latency of 160 milliseconds. And in practical deployment, it hits around 200 milliseconds.
Which is actually faster than the human conversational average of 230 milliseconds. That is insane.
It's wild. But to pull this off, the architecture has to process and generate audio natively end to end without using text as a middleman.
Which presents a massive raw data problem because uncompressed high fidelity audio is incredibly dense.
Oh, absolutely. A standard language model trying to process 24 kilohertz audio waveform data in real time would just instantly overwhelm any compute budget.
So the researchers had to figure out how to digitize the human voice into something lightweight without, you know, stripping away the nuance.
Right. And they built a neural audio codec called Mimi specifically for this. Mimi compresses that raw 24 kilohertz audio down into discrete tokens running at a frame rate of 12.5 hertz.
Okay, let's unpack this a bit, because tokenizing audio introduces a fundamental engineering tension that text models never have to deal with.
Yeah, it's a completely different beast. When you compress text, a word is just a word. But when you tokenize audio, a single token needs to carry two entirely different dimensions of information simultaneously.
Right, you need semantic tokens.
Exactly. Semantic tokens capture the linguistic meaning, the actual words being formed by the sound. But alongside that, you desperately need acoustic tokens.
And those capture the paralinguistic data, right? Like the speaker's emotion, the pitch, the timbre of their voice, the pacing, and even the ambient background noise.
Spot on. But combining those two streams creates a severe optimization conflict.
Right. It's like trying to pack a high-definition movie and the text's subtitles into the exact same file track. If the system over-optimizes for the crispness of the text, the video artifacting gets out of control.
That's a great analogy. And if it optimizes for smooth video, the subtitles get corrupted. In early iterations, the engineers tried distilling the semantic meaning using an existing model called WaveLM into the very first layer of what's called a residual vector
quantizer, or RVQ.
But that failed, didn't it?
It did. To understand why, we should look at how a standard RVQ operates. It works through successive approximation.
So the first quantizer layer takes a broad mathematical guess at the audio waveform.
Right. And the second layer looks at the residual, you know, the error left over from the first guess and tries to encode that. The third layer looks at the residual of the second and so on.
Like a painter adding progressively finer brush strokes.
Exactly. But when Q-Type forced the first semantic layer to be hyper focused on distinguishing words, it discarded so much of the raw acoustic data that the subsequent layers just had nothing left to work with.
Oh, I see. So the math forced the acoustic nuance to try and survive inside the leftovers of the semantic data.
Yeah, and the resulting audio sounded terribly degraded.
So how did they fix that mathematical bottleneck?
Through an architectural pivot they call the split RVQ. They realized they couldn't force the acoustic brushstrokes to depend on the semantic outline, so they split the workload into parallel tracks. Oh, nice. The semantic information gets distilled into its own
dedicated plain vector quantizer. It only cares about the words.
While simultaneously, they run a separate seven-level RVQ that is entirely dedicated to the acoustic information.
Exactly. By running them side by side and summing the outputs at the end, they completely remove that mathematical constraint. The acoustic data no longer has to survive inside the residual error of the semantic data.
So the perceived audio quality improved massively, while the phonetic accuracy remained razor sharp. But let me push back on this for a second. If the overarching goal is simply to build an intelligent assistant, and compute latency is our primary enemy, why not just throw
out the acoustic tokens entirely? I mean, dropping them would instantly halve the sequence length and save a massive amount of processing power, right?
It would, but throwing out the acoustic tokens forces you back into building a glorified text bot. What's fascinating here is that in human communication, paralinguistic data fundamentally alters meaning. It isn't just decorative.
Right. Tone matters.
Immensely. Think about the phrase, oh, that's just great. Spoken with a bright, enthusiastic tone, it means one thing. But spoken with the flat, downward pitch, it conveys sarcasm, meaning the exact opposite.
Ah, yeah. Or if a user is shouting at a panic, the agent needs to interpret that urgency and respond differently than if the user is whispering in a library.
Exactly. Those acoustic tokens are the only way Moshi interprets emotion, and critically, the only way it generates its own expressive, non-robotic responses.
But retaining all that rich audio data has to create a terrifying traffic jam for the transformer itself. We're running eight code books at 12.5 hertz.
Yeah, which means Moshi is generating 100 distinct tokens for every single second of audio.
So if a user has a five-minute conversation, the context window swells to 30,000 time steps, and standard transformer architectures scale quadratically. Trying to run attention mechanisms over a 30,000 token sequence would completely
obliterate that 160 millisecond latency target.
Right. A monolithic transformer simply cannot calculate relationships across that many time steps in real time. The compute overhead is just too hostile.
So how does Moshi get around it?
It circumvents this by fracturing the monolithic design into what they call an RQ transformer architecture. The workload gets divided between two distinct neural networks operating at different scales.
Okay, so what are the two networks?
Well, first, there is a massive 7 billion parameter temporal transformer built on Kutai's custom text model called Helium. And underneath that sits a much smaller, highly efficient depth transformer.
So is the relationship between those two models similar to like a restaurant kitchen?
What do you mean?
Like the massive temporal transformer acts as the head chef. operating at that base 12.5 hertz frequency, it looks at the entire 30,000 token history of the conversation and formulates the overarching context.
Oh, I like this. Yeah.
It basically declares, we are currently explaining quantum physics with a highly enthusiastic tone and passes that single context vector down.
Right. And then the smaller depth transformer acts as the line cooks. It takes that high level context and rapidly chops the ingredients, predicting the specific eight sub sequences, you know, the exact semantic and acoustic tokens for that specific fraction of a second. That maps perfectly
onto how the layers interact. Offloading the dense per code book predictions to the smaller depth transformer means the heavy seven billion parameter temporal transformer only executes once per time step rather than eight times.
Which solves the raw computation problem.
It does. But aligning the head chef and the line cooks introduces a new problem regarding the actual timing of the generation. If you try to predict the semantic and acoustic tokens at the exact same time step, like a zero delay setup, the generation quality collapses.
The model was essentially being forced to guess how a word should sound before it had fully committed to which word it was going to say.
Ah, so the engineers had to introduce a stagger, intentionally slowing the system down.
Exactly. They call it acoustic delay. By delaying the acoustic generation by just one or two frames, which is about 80 to 160 milliseconds, they give the temporal transformer a brief window of look ahead.
So it has just enough time to lock in the semantic meaning and model the complex interdependence of how that specific word should be delivered acoustically.
Right. The development team deliberately traded 160 milliseconds of raw speed for a measurable, massive boost in speech stability and a significant drop in model perplexity.
That's a fascinating trade-off. So the split RVQ preserves the audio fidelity, and the RQ transformer structure, combined with that slight acoustic delay, beats the clock. The system is fast and sounds human.
But there's a catch.
There's always a catch.
Pure audio to audio foundation models share a well-known foundational flaw. They lack deep reasoning.
Oh, right. Because a model trained strictly on raw audio waveforms becomes incredibly adept at mimicking human syntax and, like, vocal fry, but it possesses almost no factual grounding.
Right. It will sound incredibly confident while getting basic arithmetic completely wrong.
Yeah. The underlying issue is that audio datasets are sparse on complex logic compared to the density of text datasets.
Exactly. So to fix this, Moshi implements a highly unusual, almost philosophical architectural feature to bridge this gap. They call it inner monologue.
Inner monologue. Here's where it gets really interesting.
Yeah. While Moshi is generating the acoustic tokens to speak out loud, it is simultaneously predicting time-aligned text tokens as a prefix to the audio, frame by frame.
It's basically generating an internal silent textual transcript of what it's about to say milliseconds before it actually synthesizes the audio.
Right. But for developers used to the old paradigm, hearing text prefix usually triggers alarm bells.
Oh, for sure. It sounds suspiciously like a return to the chain of modality systems. Like, aren't they just building a text pipeline again? Does this ruin the real time vibe?
It would if it worked like the old systems. In those older setups, an agent has to write out an entire sentence or a full paragraph, wait for the text generation to finish, and then pass that chunk to a synthesizer.
Which creates massive latency spikes.
Exactly. But inner monologue avoids that trap completely because it operates in parallel at that strict 12.5 hertz frequency. The model predicts the text token for a specific syllable just a fraction of a second
before predicting the acoustic tokens for that exact same syllable.
So the text isn't acting as a bottleneck. It is acting as structural scaffolding.
Yes. The 7 billion parameter helium backbone inside Moshi was pre-trained on over 2 trillion tokens of dense text. It already possesses incredible factual reasoning capabilities.
So by forcing the model to internally read its own text track just before generating the sound, the architecture seamlessly aligns the deep high-level logic of a text LLM with the expressive, low-latency delivery of an audio model.
The benchmark data clearly illustrates how powerful the scaffolding is. When the researchers ran MERCI on spoken question-answering tasks without the inner monologue enabled, it scored roughly 21% accuracy on the LAMA question benchmark.
Only 21%.
Yeah. But when they activated the inner monologue, forcing that frame-by-frame text alignment, accuracy tripled to over 62%. Wow.
So the text scaffolding successfully unlocks the dormant reasoning capabilities of the helium backbone. and translates them directly into the real-time audio output.
It's incredibly elegant.
It really is. But that structural breakthrough brings us to the brutal realities of deployment. I mean, if you've ever tried to ship a 7 billion parameter dual transformer model, you know your compute budget is going to bleed.
Oh, absolutely. Running that architecture at low latency on edge devices or standard consumer hardware is prohibitively expensive. Compression is mandatory.
But applying standard compression techniques to a native speech model reveals some bizarre failure modes.
Yeah, very bizarre. Post-training quantization, or PTQ, is the standard playbook for shrinking text models. Developers routinely compress 16-bit text models down to 8-bit or even 4-bit integer quantization.
And you lose a tiny fraction of reasoning, but the model generally remains coherent.
Right. But speech models reject that kind of compression. The researchers tested pushing Moshi down to lower bit widths, specifically W2A8.
Which means quantizing the weights to two bits while keeping activations at eight bits.
Exactly. The inner monologue, you know, the text reasoning, held up relatively well. But the audio generation began to physically disintegrate.
Yikes. The paper documents very specific audio artifacts that emerge under compression, right? Like the model starts hallucinating phantom background noises.
Yeah, or it loses its grip on phonetics entirely, generating what the researchers categorize as gibberish audio. Sometimes it even gets trapped in loops, emitting this repetitive robotic stutter.
And this degradation is trackable in the raw data by monitoring token entropy, isn't it?
Yes. In a healthy model generation, the entropy, which is the measure of randomness or varied choices of both semantic and acoustic tokens, fluctuates naturally.
But under heavy two-bit quantization, the precision of the weights becomes too coarse to represent the nuanced, continuous curves of physical sound waves.
Precisely. The entropy of the audio tokens flatlines. The model mathematically gets stuck predicting the exact same token endlessly, which the user hears as a buzzing stutter. The acoustic modeling is inherently far more fragile and susceptible to
quantization errors than the abstract logic of text processing.
That entropy flatline is a massive warning sign for teams trying to optimize these dual modality models. You really cannot rely solely on text benchmarks to measure the health of a compressed speech model.
No, you can't.
But looking past the backend hurdles, the user experience this architecture unlocks is entirely novel. Because Moshi doesn't rely on voice activity detection, there is no concept of a speaker turn.
Right. Moshi utilizes multi-stream modeling. It is continuously processing the incoming stream of the user's audio and continuously outputting its own stream of audio simultaneously 100% of the time.
Wait, 100% of the time?
Yes. Even when the user is speaking and Moshi is quiet, Moshi is actively generating what the architecture defines as natural silence tokens.
Oh, wow. That constant generation is what allows the model to back channel so naturally.
Exactly. If a user is telling a complex, winding story, Moshi can drop in a quick, uh-huh, or, yeah, I see in the middle of the user sentence without breaking the flow or crashing a pipeline.
It perfectly mimics the rhythm of human active listening. But a foundation model that constantly ingests and perfectly mimics raw audio introduces a major intellectual property liability.
It does. An unaligned audio to audio model has the capacity to memorize not just factual data, but the literal pitch, melody and pacing of its training data.
Right. So without safeguards, a prompted model could flawlessly regurgitate a copyrighted song snippet or perfectly clone a specific unauthorized person's voice that it heard during pre-training.
The engineering team initially looked at text based watermarking to track outputs. But those methods degrade quickly when the audio is re-encoded or compressed later.
So what was the ultimate fix for this regurgitation risk?
It actually wasn't an architectural patch. It was a brute force data engineering solution.
Oh, really?
Yeah. The team aggressively filtered the pre-training data set to systematically strip out any highly frequent audio segments. By ensuring no specific acoustic sequence was repeated enough times to be etched into the model's weights, the regurgitation rate in the
final fine-tuned model plummeted to zero.
The model simply lacks the deep, repetitive exposure required to clone specific audio clips from memory.
Exactly.
That's a remarkably practical solution. Stepping back to look at the broader landscape, the successful deployment of multi-stream modeling, split RVQs, and the inner monologue really signals the rapid end of the cascaded voice pipeline.
It really does. The latency limits imposed by stacking discrete transcription, text generation, and synthesis models are structural dead ends. Moshi proves that by trading a small amount of architectural complexity, we can achieve sub-second,
highly intelligent conversational agents.
But there is a hidden feature inside the inner monologue architecture that feels like a genuine paradigm shift. Normally, Moshi uses that slight acoustic delay we discussed to keep the text scaffolding and the audio output tightly synced. But the
researchers discovered that the delay parameter is completely malleable.
This is my favorite part. Simply by tweaking that one timing parameter in the code, the fundamental utility of the model transforms.
Okay, break that down for us.
If you force the text stream to lead the audio stream by two full seconds and feed the model a text document, Moshi instantly becomes a zero-shot, perfectly aligned streaming text-to-speech engine. It
just stops being a conversational agent and becomes a pure synthesizer.
Exactly. And conversely, if you invert the parameter, forcing the audio stream to lead the text stream by two seconds and feed the model a live microphone feed, it acts as a high-fidelity streaming automatic speech recognition engine,
outputting highly accurate text transcripts.
Wait, really? Just by sliding the window?
Yes. This requires absolutely no changes to the loss function, no adjustments to the transformer layers, and zero retraining.
It is wild that sliding a single timing window turns one architecture into three entirely different tools.
If we connect this to the bigger picture, it forces a profound question about the future of AI infrastructure.
How so?
Well, for years, the industry has siloed its efforts, building specialized teams, distinct server architectures, and separate research branches for speech recognition, large language models, and speech synthesis. What happens to those deep, expensive tech stacks when a single unified
architecture can seamlessly subsume all three?
The entire ecosystem consolidates. We move away from piecing together rigid walkie-talkie pipelines and toward building unified systems that actually process information the way humans do. And suddenly, that awkward pause is gone forever. Something for you all to mull over as
you build out your next generation of interfaces. Thanks for joining us on this deep dive, and we'll catch you next time.